ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะค่ะนักเรียน
นักเรียนวันนี้วันอะไรคะครูฟ้า
วันนี้วันพุธที่วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
6 ที่ 28 อะไรมาจากไหนเนี่ยเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
5 ก่อน 6 เครืองอ่ะคนเดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะชาพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรคะครูฟ้าพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 7
เดือนเดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 10:00 น 10 โมง
กี่นาที
สิบโมงลดลง 5 นาทีค่ะเรา 10:05 เป็นเวลา
กลางวันนะ
ฟ้าเดือนนี้เดือนที่ 7 แล้ว
นี่ไหมคะผู้หญิง
อีห่าแต่ก็ไม่ดีค่ะแต่ก็ดีค่ะเอ้าสรุปดี
หรือไม่ดีเดือนที่เจิดเนี่ยดีดีหรือไม่ดี
ไม่รู้แต่วันที่ 5 วันที่ 6 วันที่เจ็ด
เนี่ยดี
เอาดียังไงล่ะวันที่ 5 วันที่ 6 วันที่ 7
House ก็
ดีเพราะว่าวันที่ 5 วันที่ 6 วันที่เจ็ด
เนี่ยเรายังมีเงินไงทำไมออฟฟิศเนี่ยให้
เงินแดกวันที่ 30 มิถุนายนสมัยเราได้เงิน
เลยครูฟ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยทำงานเดี๋ยวกูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงไม่ได้เงินแบบนี้นะคะแต่ถ้าเราทำ
งานออฟและกะวันที่ 30 เราได้เงิน
มันกินข้าววันที่ 6 วันที่ 7 เราก็ยังมี
เงินอยู่
ใช่กูหญิงครูฟ้าเนี่ยพึ่งได้เงินมานะคะ
วันที่
ที่ทอได้ใน
นี้วันหน้าจะวันที่ 3 มั้งค่ะวันที่ 3
June
ลาย
กรกฎาคมเอาครูฟ้าได้เงินมาก็ต้องใช้เงิน
ผู้หญิงก็ไม่รู้นะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบซื้อ
อะไร
ครูฝาหรอครูฟ้าชอบซื้อ
สีฟ้าไม่ชอบซื้อนี่ไงครูหญิงเนี่ยชอบ
ซื้อมากๆ
อะไรผู้หญิงเนี่ยชอบซื้อคู่ฟ้าเอา July
ออกไปได้ไหมคะดีมากค่ะผู้หญิงนะคะชอบซื้อ
เสื้อ
ตื่นนิ
กางเกงซื้อกาแฟโปรงงสื่อรองเท้า
ซื้อกระเป๋าหนูผู้หญิงมีเงินไหมคะ
2 ซื้อ
ๆจะว่างอ่ะเวลาที่เราซื้อสมัยเรามีเงิน
แล้วเราก็ซื้อเสื้อและเสื้อมันก็จะมีมัน
จะมีอันนี้ใช่ไหมแล้วก็จะมีเป็นเอาสีอื่น
ใช่ไหมมีเป็นเป็นป้ายยังมีป้ายยี่ห้อค่ะ
วันนี้เป็นอะไรดีค่ะ H  sand-m ป้าย
ยี่ห้อเหมือนกางเกงสมัยกางเกงก็มีป้ายกับ
โปร่งกระเป๋ารองเท้าเนี่ยของใหม่
ผู้หญิงชอบของใหม่หรอพร้อมของใหม่เวลาโดม
เนี่ย
มันหอมมีกลิ่นใหม่อ๋ออ๋อกลิ่นใหม่แล้วนะ
เรียนเนี่ยได้ยินไหมเวลาทิพย์บอกมามันจะ
มีกี่ใหม่รองเท้า
เขาไม่ดมนะคะเอารองเท้าก็มีกลิ่นใหม่มั้ย
ล่ะกลิ่นใหม่ไงผู้หญิงอ่ะก็เลยมีคำถามมี
คำถามหรอ
คำถามหรือเปล่าก็ไปทำถามนั่นแหละถามก็
อยากจะถามครูฟาว่าเวลาครูฟ้าซื้อเสื้อ
ซื้อกางเกงซื้อกระโปรง
กระเป๋าไม่เนาะร้านรองเท้าไม่นะคะซื้อ
ใหม่เนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ย
a  a
นะค่ะ A อ่ะมันสูงไปเนาะขยับลงมานิดนึงนะ
คะ a เนี่ยครูฟ้าซัก
นี้เป็นเครื่องซักผ้าใช่ไหมเสื้อที่ซื้อ
มาใหม่เนี่ยกูฟ้าเนี่ยสัตว์ก่อน
แล้ว
กูฟ้าก็ใส่
แต่กูไปเอเอเนี่ยซักก่อนใส
แต่ถ้าบี
บี
กับพี่นะคะขี้เกียจว่าเอ้า
มีเนี่ยครูฟ้าใส่
ใส่ก่อนซักอาน่า
ไปซักก่อนไฟหรือ
ใส่ก่อนซักใช่ไหมคะเอาเวลาที่เราเนี่ย
ซื้อเสื้อผ้ามาใหม่เนี่ยมันก็จะมีคน 2
แบบแบบ a ก็คือทรัพย์เสร็จแล้วก็ใส่แบ่ง
ดีแล้วจะซื้อมาปุ๊ป
ใหม่ใส่ก่อนซักครูฟ้าเป็นแบบไหน
แบบฟรี
ไม่มี
มีแค่เอซัสก่อนใส่เรื่องที่ใส่ก่อนซักกู
ฟ้าเป็นแบบไหน
ครูมาเนี่ยอ่ะ
ถ้าเป็นแบบ
a ค่ะวงอะไรเด้อเดี๋ยวก็เป็นแบบสีอะเอ้า
ๆเป็นแบบเอง ecru หญิงหูว่าเป็นแบบ a นะ
คะรู้ฟ้าซัดก่อนใส่หรอได้สิเวลากูฟ้าไป
ช้อปปิ้งใช่ไหมค่ะอยู่จะเก็บร้านเสื้อผ้า
ณร้าน
เลือกนางงามผู้หญิงผู้หญิงไม่เอาครูฟ้าไป
ซื้อเสื้ออ่าซื้อเสื้อๆนะไม่บอกว่าทำไม
ไม่เข้าใจเลยแล้วนะฮะบอกว่าได้
เพื่อนใหม่ใช่ไหมไม่เคยมีคนใส่ของใหม่ใช่
ของใหม่นะคะแต่เวลาฟ้าไปซื้อเสื้อ
มันก็จะคิดเอง
ถ้าเกิดฟ้าซื้อเสื้อม้าเสื้อเนี่ยมันอยู่
ที่ร้านใช่ไหมก็จะรางอันนี้จะเป็นร้านอาจ
จะเป็น Uniqlo  Zara  hm หรือว่าร้านที่
JJ สมัยจตุจักรใช่ว่าคิดว่าเสื้อเนี่ย
มันอยู่ที่ร้าน
1เดือน
2เดือน
หรือว่า 3 ปี
อันนั้นก็
มาเก็บไปว่าจะนานไปหรือเปล่าฉันขายไม่ใช่
ไม่โอเคนะ
อาจจะแบบว่า1เดือน2เดือน3เดือนคือเสื้อใน
มันอยู่ที่ร้านนาน
ๆใช่ไหมนักเรียน
ก็จะคิดเองเข้ากูฟ้าซื้อเสื้อ
แล้วฟ้าใส่
ว่าจะอัดใช่หรือเปล่าหลวงพ่อกูพาเป็น
อีกทีนะคะว่าใช่ใช่บ่อยๆไง
ก็เลยคิดเองฝากซื้อเสื้อแล้วใส่โอเคไหม
ใช้หูฟังน้า
มาช่วยภูฟ้าเวลาเราซื้อเสื้อมาใหม่เนี่ยะ
เสื้อเนี่ยมันซักแล้วซักแล้ว
แต่มั้ย
เอ้าแต่เสื้อในมันอยู่ที่ร้าน1เดือน
2เดือน3เดือนมันก็จะมีคน
คน
คนมาจับ
ขอ
ว่าอะไรอย่างนี้ไงกิ่งศัพท์ว่าตัวเองต้อง
ซักไหมครูฟ้าแต่ถ้าครู Fast เนี่ยเสื้อ
เนี่ยไม่มีกลิ่นใหม่ผู้หญิงชอบกลิ่นใหม่
หรอขอผู้หญิงเนี่ยชอบเวลาซื้อเสื้อมา
เนี่ยชอบใส่แล้วก็ดม
เสื้อใหม่ไม่เคยเพิ่งซื้อมาเสือผู้หญิง
เลยต้องใส่ก่อนซักข่าผู้หญิงนะฮะอะไรคะ
ลบได้นะครับรูฝา
เต็มมากผู้หญิงแกะโลโก้ย
แก่
ผู้หญิงซื้อเอาเวลาผู้หญิงซื้อเสื้อมา
ทำไมซื้อเสื้อมาเนี่ยเสื้อเสื้อ
เนี่ยมันก็จะมีป้ายเนี่ยที่เป็นโลโก้นะคะ
ที่ภูฟ้าบอกเนี่ย
ผ่านสมุด
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยก็เอา
กรรไกรสมัยกรรไกรเนี่ยกรรไกรเนี่ยตัดตัด
โลโก้ต่อแล้วก็ใส่
เสื้อใหม่คุณก็เลยเป็นคนที่ใส่โอ้นี่ก่อน
สัตว์ไม่สัตว์ก่อนใส่ไม่ได้เราต้องซัก
ก่อนใส่แต่กูฟ้าเนี่ยซักเสื้อนากู้ภายใน
ได้เสื้อมา
ทำไมซื้อเบี้ยวจัง
ฟ้าแปลชื่อเนื้ออาซื้อเสื้อมานะคะแขนเป็น
แล้วก็มาก็มีโลโก้ใช่ไหมค่ะ
ก็เอาไปซักค่ะผู้หญิง
โลโก้ไหมคะไม่ตัด
กูมั้ยกูฟ้าเนี่ยสัตว์แล้วก็มีลงทุนอยู่
แล้วก็ใส่แล้วก็มีโลโก้อยู่
วันที่มีพลาสติกแล้วพลาสติกอยู่นี่ size
sml อะไรเนี่ยอ่ะคุณครูหญิงเนี่ยผู้หญิง
เนี่ยเป็นคนที่
ใช่ก่อนซักใช่ไหมใส่ค่ะเคยซื้อเสื้อเคย
ซื้อเสื้อมา 1 ครั้ง
มันจะมีเสื้อยี่ห้อแบบตอนนั้นอ่ะ Uniqlo
มั้งตอนนี้ครั้งหน้าใช่ไหมข้างหน้าแต่
เสื้อมันจะมีข้างหลัง
ข้างหลังข้างหน้าเนี่ยมันอาจจะมีแบบว่า
อาจ size  size  L  size  L  size  L
เนี่ยเล่าเหตุเวลาเราจะใส่ไหมว่าผู้หญิง
ยังไม่ได้สัตว์ปีกก็จะดึง Sticker  on
Journey เป็นไซส์ L ออกแต่เราไม่เห็นว่า
ข้างหลังตรงเนี้ย
มันมีไซส์ L อยู่
ให้บอกว่าเป็นคนไม่ซับใจไม่สั่งซื้อเสื้อ
มาปุ๊บต้องใส่ก่อนนะมันมีสติ๊กเกอร์อยู่
ข้างหลังคุณ
เลือกครีมใส่ก่อนซักแต่ก็บางครั้งก็ไม่
โอเคนะไม่เช็คก่อนไงแต่กูฟ้าเนี่ยซักก่อน
นะคะก็ไม่แก่
กูไม่แกะสติ๊กเกอร์ออกแล้วเนียนหัวคิดว่า
ชื่ออะไรแล้วถ้าครูฟ้าซื้อกางเกงล่ะ
กางเกง
เป็นกางเกงยีนส์น้องแบบรีไวล์
แม็คยีนส์กางเกงยีนเนี่ยครูฟ้า
ซักก่อนใส่หรือว่าใส่ก่อนซักกางเกงอ่ะ
กางเกงมีหนึ่งว่าบางคนเนี่ยถ้าเป็นเสื้อ
อ่ะซะก่อนใส่
แต่กางเกงอาจจะไม่เหมือนกัน
กางเกงยีนส์กูฟ้าก็ซักก่อนค่ะสัตว์อ่ะ
[เพลง]
จะมาหาที่
ครูบอกว่าเหมือนเดิมนะคะซักแล้วมีโลโก้รถ
ก็นักเรียนบ่เข้าใจสังคมไม้สักแต่มีโลโก้
หรือซักเลยทันทีนะฮะ Out กางเกงยีนส์อ่ะ
คือเค้าเป็นคนที่ชอบใส่กางเกงยีนส์นะแต่
เวลาใส่กางเกงยีนส์อ่ะฟ้าใส่กางเกงยีนส์
ใช่ไหมมันจะขาดนะเนี่ย
กูปักคันมากเลยอ่ะคันขาแบบคันเออแล้วนะ
ไม่ตอนยังไม่ได้ซักอ่ะต่อ
ให้เกิดกูฟ้าไม่ซักกางเกงอั้ม
ไม่ซักกางเกงยีนส์เนี่ยกูพระจักคัน
ขันฟ้าก็เลยต้องซักกางเกงยีนส์ก่อน
แต่สมัยก็เอามาเกยีนอ่ะมาซักนะมี
อ้าพอสักแล้วก็โอเคไม่คันครูฟ้าก็เลยเป็น
ทีมซับก่อนใส่แล้วกางเกงยีนส์ล่ะผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงซักกางเกงยีนส์ไหมเสื้อกูยังไม่
ซักเลยฟ้า
ทุกอย่างที่ซื้อมาใหม่เนี่ยผู้หญิงไส้
ก่อนทรัพย์ค่ะหนูลุกอย่างเลยหรอยกเว้นชุด
ข้างในนะคะเหมือนชุดชั้นในเนี่ยไม่ๆๆๆ
ชุดชั้นในเนี่ยเหมือนครูฟ้าเนาะต้องอื่น
ใส่กลางในใช่ไหมคะที่จะเป็นเสื้อว่าได้
ใช่ไหมไม่เป็นไรใช่ไหมคะได้ค่ะไม่เป็นไร
สวยที่มันจะเป็นเสื้อในแล้วก็กางเกงใน
อันเนี้ยผู้หญิงเนี่ยเบื่อเหมือนครูฟ้า
ซัดก่อนใส่อ่าแต่ถ้าเป็น
มีกางเกงยีนส์หรือว่าเสื้อเนาะแล้วก็กลับ
ลง
กระโปร่งล่ะถ้าไฟฟ้าซื้อกับโรงครูฟ้าก็
ซัดก่อนใส่เหมือนกันใช่ฮะซักก่อนใส่
เหมือนกันค่ะผู้หญิงแต่ผู้ฟ้าจะมีหนึ่ง
อย่างที่กูฟังไม่ซักอะไรคะ
นั่นก็คือ
ทำยำแทง
ลงไป
ที่ครูฟ้าซื้อมาแล้วครูป๊าจัดใส่ก่อนซัด
อะไรอ่ะคะ
ไม่ใช่คุมไป
หมวดหมู่รถใช่นี่ไง
กูสองหัวปลาช่องใส่กันแบบนี้ไม่ใช่หรอคะ
ตัว
การ์ตูนเหมือนกัน
กอล์ฟ
ซื้อหมวกมาเนี่ยพูดว่าจะใส่ก่อนกุมภาสั้น
พวกด้วยหรอถึงไม่
เอาก็ต้องพักนะว่าเฮียรักหนูก็ซักนะกูฟัง
แล้ว
กูฝาซื้อซื้อรองเท้าอ่ะมันจะพูดอะไรผู้
หญิง
3 ก่อนแล้วก็ใส่หรอรองเท้ากว้างกูฟ้า
เนี่ยซักทุกอย่างนะคะซักหมวกซักเสื้อซัก
กางเกงซักกระโปรงแต่คู่ฟ้าไม่ซัดรองเท้า
ค่ะ
ว่าไม่เคยซักลงน่ะ
มีรถทุกคนเหมือนกันนะพูดคิดคงไม่ซักรองก็
มีแต่บอกว่าคนรอบรู้ก็ทุกคนฟักนะหรอใช่
คือแบบถ้าสุดรองเท้ามันเป็นสีดำใช่ไหมคะ
แต่ว่าไม่ได้แต่ถ้าซื้อมาเนี่ยก็ใส่ก่อน
ซักใช่ไหมอ่ะถ้าซื้อมาไม่ใช่ฮะแต่ว่ากูไป
ไม่ซักรองเท้าเลยอ่ะ Never ไม่อยู่เหมือน
ยาแก่ผู้หญิงก็ไม่
ใส่มาทิ้ง
ครูหญิงอ่ะนะคะเวลาซื้ออะไรมาทุกอย่างที่
เป็นเสื้อนอกกางเกงจะโปร่งบ่วงครูหญิง
เนี่ยเป็นคนที่ใส่ก่อนสัตว์
แด่ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นทีมซัดก่อนใส่ในฮะ
นักเรียนล่ะคะ
นักเรียนใส่ก่อนฟักหรือซักก่อนใส่คะนัก
เรียนถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยเธอเป็นคนที่ใส่
ก่อนซักก็เหมือนครูหญิงสมัยซื้อมาแล้วก็
ใส่แล้วก็
กลิ่นใหม่แต่ถ้านักเรียนเป็นคนที่ซักก่อน
แล้วก็ใส่ก็เหมือนครูฟ้าน่าดูอัดทันสมัย
อาจารย์คัน
ใช่คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะว่านักเรียน
เนี่ย
สร้างก่อนใส่หรือว่าใส่ก่อนซักเนาะทั้ง
นั้นเมื่อคืนนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้าสวัสดีค่ะให้
โน้ท